we begin tonight with a disturbing and
dangerous trend from President Trump's
opponents questioning the mental fitness
of our commander-in-chief President
Trump did nothing to hide his brash
style during his raucous campaign
rallies and he still won a clear victory
in the electoral college over Hillary
Clinton that hasn't stopped his
opposition from hurling accusations
against the president that are outside
the bounds of common political discourse
I think that President Trump's his
antics his theater his entertaining
personality his erratic behavior should
be of concern to anyone who has
dedicated themselves to the preservation
of our democracy and our national
security in discussions among friends
and family and debates on social media
people are questioning the president's
fitness I really questioned question his
ability to his fitness to be in this
office I certainly think that there's an
issue with the president's capability
it's actually a growing mountain of
evidence that the president has been
very erratic has shown a mental
instability all right Greg so if Trump
is crazy what does that make Hillary she
lost to a crazy person it's interesting
everybody there mentions these generic
terms a growing amount of evidence
growing mountain of evidence his
behavior but they don't mention actual
specific facts because there aren't any
but I understand this Trump is a heavy
lift for people he was a heavy lift for
me during that during the the election
what he called the nomination the kaepa
campaign he's rude he's brash he's silly
he's childish but if but he's also very
funny
if you obsessively pay attention to
everything he says and believe that he
is completely serious the whole time he
is going to drive you crazy when you're
seeing is a collective drug trip that
the media is sharing right now they
really do believe they see a horrifying
monster they think they're seeing a
monster because they're all high on this
emotional belief without the evidence
what I don't understand is that a lot of
these reporters and a lot of these
comments
have been around there as old as I am so
they've seen hysteria and scares before
they have seen y2k and remember LR from
the apples and heavy metal and red meat
and reefer all of the scares nothing is
ever as bad as they think it is in fact
it never is even people who thought
Obama was evil have to admit he wasn't
so what we're going through is another
collective scare I just don't understand
how the media doesn't see this how they
don't realize that they're in in this
weird hysterical bubble he's not what
you think he is he's not Dana why don't
you think the Democrats try the
traditional way of removing a president
which is beating him at the ballot box
ideas with ideas and Greg said they
never go after policy they just go after
him personally
well I think well I guess by because
it's the cheaper shot it is easier it's
interesting if you think back I guess
all of us are maybe guilty since Freud
like trying to psychoanalyze other
people because we read we took a
psychology 101 like oh well then that
must be this and I remember for
President Bush the media used to always
want to write stories about how he must
have very a lot of difficulties and have
an inferiority complex because his
father was president and so he would be
reluctant sometimes to do interviews
with the media because he would say all
I want to do is put me on the couch and
they want to try to play armchair
psychiatrist to try to get into my
psyche when he's like he's like actually
you know what I believe life begins at
conception it's not some like daddy
complex that I have it there just belief
that I have and so I do think that this
is new that they've crossed a line I
think with this and questioning
somebody's mental health seems to be
really beyond the pale it does and
unnecessary we caught we had you have to
admit there were people doing that to be
fair to Hillary about her health
not her mental that's true yeah a lot so
I mean we all kind of do it don't we
Tammy will you to see him that all
choice all right I'm sorry Kimberly um
KJ yeah voters wanted somebody brash
they wanted someone new they wanted
someone to come in here in
flip up the table that's what they got
it just seems like a lot of people have
a hard time accepting the will of the
people yeah but I think these are the
same people that in fact didn't favor a
trump presidency I think the people that
support the president the true like
hardcore you know Baga followers out
there they like what they see
gays love it it's red meat when he's at
these rallies and he's out there and
he's doing his thing and he's blaming
the media on fake news and saying that
he's getting a raw deal from them and he
calls mouths they love it they figured
get enough people that are upset of the
people that weren't really truly in
favor of him getting into office that
had reservation so this just sort of
plays into their preconceived notions
okay they already had this planned you
know resentment of him baked in before
he even walked to into the White House
and in terms of the mainstream media I
mean they never liked him to begin with
I mean they were saying these kind of
things about him before you know he took
the office while he was running saying
so unfit this isn't appropriate he's
gonna drop out all of a sudden I never
had a real they never wanted to be 16
other people and by the way he's having
you know a good time in terms of he's
being himself he's saying what he thinks
he's putting it out there like no one
could control me I'm telling you
psychologically this is what's going on
he thinks it's fine when they're talking
about okay he sent this tweet out about
me guys that whoa they're talking about
North Korea no they talking about health
care not going through nope
so that's part of his like throw him off
kilter let him chase you know the rabbit
outside the yard well hold on a second
now I mean I see that warning on the
screen there about a hurricane in Texas
I think the hurricane must have swept
through here because I know and I've
seen quotes from Republicans who say you
know what I don't think he's
demonstrated stability they don't like
bob corker of tennessee who was a trump
supporter Kimberly and you know what
when people's that talk about Trump Greg
they say very specific thing they say
narcissism grandiosity right they say
that he's impulsive at times reckless
that's actually not at all evidence
that's a discriminatory that salad but
would you whatever kill you give me a
deed okay so would you say that it's
grandiose to say my inauguration crowd
was bigger than any other crowd despite
evidence
Cheers demonstrate that in fact no this
is what this is about is I'm going to
prove myself right no matter what the
facts may show that is that no that is
part of a brass personality that does
that is that people find it actually
funny
well you're mining a funny it's triggers
you it makes me laugh it might be funny
it's funny to people like Jim clapper
who is national telling who says it's
shocking you got a question the fitness
for office where he's not the National
Authority when he's talking out large
crowds he's insane
well I don't got a lease at eleven quite
early tremendous need to be right about
everything to prove himself right so why
winning you're gonna buy it away well I
think when when politicians call other
politicians narcissists I think the
ironies lost Tiree no I don't know Obama
never had an ego one recalls in the
concert a lot of politicians are psycho
I mean I live with them so RT know he
thought but this is absolutely no this
isn't mrs. grandiosity and guess what
how are you late people you say oh it's
just people who don't like it well guess
what 55% in a morning consult poll said
Trump is not stable yeah fun I just
wasn't stable conventional politicians
have gotten us trillion trillion dollars
into debt open borders and stagnant
wages so that's why Donald Trump was
elected let's talk about the politics of
maybe overreaching David Axelrod
President Obama's chief strategist had
this to say if people get a sense that
there's some extraordinary measure
that's going to be taken to effect what
they would view as a bloodless coup
remember a third of the country supports
this president that's a very dangerous
road to go down and if you ever did go
down that road you're opening a
Pandora's box that will never end so you
think he has a point
absolutely and I think that like that's
a true public servant someone who's been
on the inside and nose and look
President Obama took a lot of flack from
lots of people all around about you know
his citizenship is the fact that he was
aloof that he was an only child and for
therefore that he must have these
harboring of like being lonely and it
has to be although I just think that
let's not take X Y for example let me
Corker for example because what one was
saying I actually think sometimes when
people say things like that about
stability that it's not about mental
health necessarily it is about the
ability to focus on an issue in order to
get it done and I think that the
Democrats would probably worry so
imagine if the mantra on Tuesday night's
rally in Phoenix was tax reform here's
the here's my three principles the three
things I want to get done and I want
every one of you to be on Facebook and
Twitter tomorrow I mean calling your
Congressman and absolute ability to
focus I think that that's where the
criticism from the right is coming when
they suggest that it's not stable that's
absolutely right and what you said
that's not about mental illness no but
you know what know he went on to say he
hasn't demonstrated the ability to have
a comprehensive strategy talking about
but he also said the business about not
demonstrated stability but you need to
realize that what's going on today in
Washington is Trump comes out he has a
Twitter storm in the morning and guess
what he's going after the Senate
Majority Leader he's back on everybody
about repealing replacing people and I'm
talking about Republicans are like what
is that why is he attacking us I guess
he's shaking things up he's doing
exactly what he said he was here is that
going to get my gist later but general
would you want him to reveal replace
Obamacare facility effective president
like potentially ill and install okay
why do you what sorry Kimberly why do
the Democrats want to remove Trump so
quickly if he's so ineffective and not
getting anything done why wouldn't they
want to keep him there for three and a
half years yeah because he actually
maybe you care about America the art
thing you want to ivana care repeal and
replace no I don't want it repealed and
replaced but I'm saying you want to
somewhat well yeah everybody wants to
pay less height but you know what you
want somebody there who's not screaming
fire and fury and a nut bag and that
worker wait wait wait that actually
works so you're going to state that that
was an insane that was an example of
insane behavior that worked look you
gotta you got to offer proof think good
things have happened in the last six
months we go through that list all the
time we have lower regulations we got
the Paris Accords gone we got lower
unemployment we've got a higher stock
market let's see what else there's a
couple of things I've left off here
North is much more secure doors cradle
anyway here's the thing this is this is
a massive the
is a hysterical event that was a
reaction to an election when something
makes you nervous when something makes
you nervous
the uncertainty leads to fear and so
there's a lot of people in this country
who are operating from that uncertainty
I would say that everybody that was
that's been in this segment and
including one the uncertainty makes them
fearful but then there's the rest of us
who are going you guys it's not bad
you're you're erupting over his words
and his mannerisms
but everything over here is all okay
sure he make sure he's not exactly the
most artful speaker and he could have
done better here and there but those
again are words and he's not going to
he's not going to soothe your soul wand
he's not going to do it him no matter
how hard last we want it they're just
desperate to try to get him out of
office so they'll lie they'll cheat
they'll make up something and call
mentally ill which is disgusting because
there's no evidence legally to support
that so these people could just sit in
their own stew for the rest of his term
because he's not going anywhere and he's
not going to be pulled out of office for
being mentally ill because people have
like a semantic psychosis over fire and
fury that work I mean it's just the most
ridiculous thing I've heard I would like
to sit in my stew sounds like fun no
just sit there no examples in it and did
you just eat the beef around you you you
not only feel warm but sir enjoy the
nutrients coming up more